welcome back to 284 news breaking news
in the british virgin islands with the
arrival
in the virgin islands of the right
honorable sir jeffrey cox husey there
to take a highly paid role in an
anti-corruption inquiry as a barrister
arguing on the side of the british
virgin islands
in this inquiry jeffrey cox is clear
politics means principles the purpose of
elected office is to serve the public
um it is not to enrich the office holder
and it is not to enrich the office
holders personal connections
clarity there in june from sir jeffrey
during his second visit to the british
virgin islands clarity 2 in this
document the register of members
interests which shows he was getting 400
000 pounds a year from a law firm for
this and other work meanwhile on the
same day he was working in the british
virgin islands sir jeffrey was also
taking part remotely in this
the eyes to the right a vote on the
future of the steel industry only
possible because of coronavirus which
allowed mps who weren't there to
participate tory colleagues are not
impressed being a member of parliament
is a full-time job so um i don't think
you can have a full-time job as well as
another full-time job there isn't enough
hours in the day to be an mp and a
full-time job
jeffrey cox was still away from his
storage in west devon constituency
abroad we were told today when the news
broke constituents who voted repeatedly
for him knowing his legal commitment
dissecting his work practices this year
he's been a very good constituent pete
but he's here i think how much better it
would be if he was full-time
nice work if you can get it but quite
honestly i think it's totally totally
immoral labor condemn his actions but
cannot point to a rule he has broken
well obviously his protectors might say
that when you look at the rules there
may not be a formal breaking of the
rules but that's the problem labor can't
point to a rule that jeffrey cox has
broken they've always been grey areas in
the system was kierstarmo wrong to take
paid legal work after he became an mp
liberal democrat leader ed davey took
consultancy work to pay for his disabled
son was that wrong
we can't both say that we want to trust
our mps and regulate every bit of their
behavior
some like the british virgin islands for
its beaches some like it for its forests
others for its tax loopholes
few think it's where mps go to work
sam cote sky news